Now that we know a little bit about what the Merge Actor tool does,
I'd like to talk about the Hierarchical Level of Detail tool, or HLOD.
HLOD is a way to replace lots of individual static mesh actors with one single static mesh actor that has one material,
and because of this, it's going to be cheaper to render.
This tool works by going through all of the static meshes placed in your level,
and it will group them based on their distance from one another.
It will then create new mesh and materials to replace the static meshes in those groups,
so that as the user progresses through the world, distance detail will be cheaper to render,
and as the user gets closer and closer to that detail, it will then be replaced with the original static meshes.
Again, the main reason to use these tools are to help lessen the rendering cost of your level's objects and distance.
Now to access the HLOD tools, or the Hierarchical Level of Detail Outliner,
you need to go to Window, and then select Hierarchical LOD Outliner from the menu.
If this option is grayed out, that means you are using a level that works with World Partition,
and we will cover how to set up HLOD with World Partition later on in this video tutorial.
Let's go ahead and pop over to the editor now and have a look at how this works.
Now inside of the Unreal Engine 5 editor, let's look at how we can utilize HLOD.
So our example here, what we're going to try and do is we're going to try to make different HLOD groups
that include this table, the chairs, and the statue, as well as the little platform underneath them,
and then make another group that contains these two over here, as well as these two over here,
and then make one final group that actually includes everything together.
And to do this, there's a couple of things we need to do first.
First off, we're going to need to open up the tool by coming up here to Window,
and then Hierarchical LOD Outliner, and this is going to open up our tool for us.
Now, if we try to do regenerate or build, nothing is going to happen,
and that's because under our HLOD system, notice we have no HLOD setup asset.
Now, a setup asset allows us to actually share this setup among different levels.
If we're just working in a single level and we don't need to have additional levels,
if we come over here to World Settings under HLOD System, under the Hierarchical LOD Setup,
if we press this plus, what we're going to do is we are going to add our different levels here.
So we can, again, set this up using a Blueprint asset, and we can do that by coming here to our Content Browser.
We can right-click, come to our Blueprint class.
We want to come down to our All Classes, and we're going to look for our, not our Blueprint, I'm sorry, our HLOD,
and then we can select our Hierarchical LOD Setup and click Select,
and let's just double-click on this to open it up.
So one of the things else that we can do is we don't need to use the Blueprint Graph,
so if we close this and we come here and we actually open this again,
we're going to get this without the full Blueprint Graph as a data-only Blueprint.
Now, before I go further, depending on which one we use, the settings are going to be the same,
whether we set this up in the level or set this up as an asset.
So let's take a look at the settings really quick.
First off, we have Cluster Generation.
Cluster Generation allows us to control the size at which static meshes should be considered to be in this cluster.
So if I have two static meshes sitting next to one another and a desired bounds of 2,000,
if those meshes are within 2,000 Unreal units of one another, they will be inside of this cluster.
The other settings that I have here control things like how much of this asset needs to be inside of this cluster
to be considered part of this cluster so we can make things more aggressive or less aggressive.
Underneath Cluster Generation Settings, we have our Mesh Generation Settings.
What this allows us to do is actually generate brand new geometry and materials
based on the settings that we need for our individual project.
We can either merge things down so that they require one mesh and one material,
or if that doesn't work, we can actually generate brand new meshes and materials
that completely replace the objects we have selected for using HLOD.
For our system here, what I'm going to do is I'm going to hit this HLOD level 0.
I'm going to hit once, and then I'm going to hit it again.
Under our Cluster Generation Settings, I'm going to set this first value to something really low, like 225.
I'm going to come here to our HLOD level 1, and I'm going to set this one to something like, I don't know, like 1800.
Then I'm going to set this very last one to something like, we'll say 2,000 would be good.
Let's go ahead and compile and save that.
What we can do here is if I hit CTRL space, make sure I have that selected,
I can come here and add that and regenerate my clusters.
Once I've done that, what's going to happen is, you can see here I have my LOD actor 0, which is right here.
I have my second one, which is going to be over there, and then my third one, which is over there, and then my fourth one.
Then my second level is going to contain actually the LOD actor.
It contains these three and the floor, and then this one contains those two and the floor there.
Not exactly what I wanted, but we could adjust the values a little bit, but it's close enough.
We did want them split into two actors.
Last but not least, we have this last LOD level that's actually going to be the floor over here,
and everything pretty much combined together.
This is good. This is exactly what we want.
Now that we know that everything is working, I'm going to hit this Build All.
We'll be right back once this builds to show you what it's actually doing.
Now that that's built, what we've done is a couple of really, really cool things here.
This will automatically switch the level of detail levels.
You can see here as I start to move away, the statue makes a very obvious switch right there.
One of the things that it's also doing is it's also actually reducing the number of triangles
versus what I'm seeing here up close.
Up close, each one of these little bits of chairs, tables, and statues
are going to consume about 10,000 triangles.
Now, using the HLOD system, when it combines all of this together
and we see the statue is something like this,
that's actually only 2,400 triangles, or about a 75% reduction in triangles.
Now, this gets further reduced as we start to go down the LOD levels.
If I come here and I go to my LOD level 1, which is this right here.
Check this out. This would be 30,000, and that gets reduced to about 7,500.
Again, down here, this one would be 10,000, and that gets reduced to 2,600.
Finally, if we go to our very last LOD level, we're going to see here that
it would come in at about 40,000, and it's been reduced to 10,000,
retaining again about 25%, 26% across the board.
This is a really, really, really amazing thing that we can do in terms of performance.
The other cool thing about this is check this out.
I'm just going to come here. I'm going to hit CTRL-H to unhide everything.
I'm not sure why it's decided to not show up.
Let's just regenerate clusters real quick.
There we go.
I wanted to do this because the system, once we have it set up,
if I come here and I move something like this,
oops, I didn't want to actually do that.
I want to disable that. There we go.
I wanted to do something like this, and then maybe I'll come over here,
and I'll even do something like add a cube here.
It's a cube.
We'll even make it a little more fancy.
We'll come here to our, got some starter content,
and we'll come to our materials, and we'll just add this concrete tile,
and we'll add this brick here.
Maybe we'll do something else.
We'll add a metal or something like that.
Let's go ahead and build all, and we'll be right back to check this out.
All right, now that we have everything built,
let's go ahead and see what's going on.
We have our LOD set to auto.
As I start to move around the scene, what's going to happen is
it's going to automatically change.
We can see here there's a change back there.
If we were to select some different things,
we would see this is going to be our big LOD actor back there.
Let's take a closer look at what's going on by just coming here
and doing our LOD one.
There's our LOD one.
I should say LOD one.
That's what I wanted to click on.
Then we can come down to our LOD two.
You can see here it's actually changing everything for us,
and we have the ability to control all of these settings.
Again, if we come back to our,
I'm going to come up here and I'm going to browse to this
inside of our content browser and open it up real quick.
There we go.
If we come down to this mesh generation,
you can see here under our merge settings,
we have all types of different settings that we can adjust
that will affect how this is merged down.
We also can change the simplification method
from merged to simplified,
which will give us a new proxy geometry or approximate.
The difference between approximate and simplify
have to deal with if you're using Nanite or not.
If you're using non-Nanite meshes, you'll want to use simplify.
If you're using approximate, you'll want to use that for any Nanite meshes.
The hierarchical level of detail tool works great for single levels.
In the next part of this video,
we're going to show you how you can work with the hierarchical level of detail tool
when it comes to world partition or massive open world style levels.
Now that we understand how the HLOD system works,
let's talk about HLOD when using things like world partition.
Now, on the screen in front of us, we have the editor using the world partition map
and I've set up something similar to what we had before,
the table and chairs and the statue.
And above each statue is a little bit of text
and this text says approximate mesh, simplified mesh, instancing and merge mesh.
Now, if I come up here to window,
I want to point out that the hierarchical LOD outliner is not here.
And the reason it's not here is that while this tool is still used,
the way we use this tool is slightly different.
What we do is for the type of HLOD system we wish a certain mesh to use,
we can assign that mesh an HLOD asset.
So for example, if I come over here to this approximate mesh,
if I come over to the details panel and I'm just going to search for HLOD,
we can see here under the HLOD layer, if I pull this over,
we're going to have the HLOD approximate merge mesh.
Now, if I browse to this asset and open it up,
you're going to see here that it is an asset that can exist inside of the content browser.
And then underneath here, I have my mesh approximate settings, which I can adjust.
And if I look at the other settings here, or the other meshes, I should say,
you can see here I have the simplified mesh, which is going to simplify our mesh
and instancing and so on and so forth all the way down to merge mesh.
Now again, to make these, all you do is you come in here,
we are going to right click and go to miscellaneous,
and then we select HLOD layer.
Once we've done that, we give it a name.
And then when we open it up, we just simply select the layer type we wish.
Up here at the top, instancing, merge mesh, simplified mesh, or approximate mesh.
Once we've built our level of details, we'll then see the results.
And one of the cool things that we can actually do here is I'm actually going to hide this.
I'm going to come here to this LOD and I'm going to unhide these
by clicking on these little pins here.
This will unhide this for us, might get a little error here.
But one of the cool things that we can do,
and we're going to unhide this one as well,
is when we select on these, if we want to rebuild this,
and we can see kind of the results here,
what we can do is we can select this.
We can actually not right click, but select one of these.
And then inside of the details panel, we can click on this build HLOD.
And this will actually build this one single HLOD.
So anything that we have done to it will be built.
So let's just give this a second to finish up
and we'll make a change and we'll come right back.
All right, and thanks to a little bit of movie magic,
we have now finished rebuilding that one.
So it took a little bit longer than I expected,
but the results are still what we're seeing right here in front of us.
We get this for the approximate mesh.
We get this for the simplified mesh.
One thing about simplified mesh I want to point out,
even though it looks bad, it's actually meant to be viewed
probably about from like this far away.
So just keep that in mind.
That's why it kind of breaks down so much.
It's not actually meant to be viewed very, very close like it is
because it's going to try to simplify this thing around kind of like a volume.
So instancing is going to allow us to have some instances.
Now, again, one thing I want to point about instancing
is we have this static mesh instant component.
We have another component and another one.
Still, we need to make sure because we see we have these static mesh
and the table and then the chair.
So this right here is two or three of them,
but these two are going to be unique.
So just keep that in mind.
We want to make sure that when we instance,
we're instancing things that are all of the same type.
It's not to say that you can't have multiple objects
that aren't of the same type make use of instancing.
It's just not going to be as efficient.
Finally, down here, we have our merged mesh.
This is literally going to make us a new mesh here
that is actually completely all merged together with everything
using the lowest level of detail.
So it's going to make things a little bit cheaper.
So again, the thing to take away from this is that
when we utilize HLOD inside of our world partition level,
we assign our individual actors in HLOD asset
that is created inside of the browser here.
And we can then use that asset
to make adjustments to groups on a whole.